as the binding administration works to
deport thousands of mostly haitian
migrants from an encampment in del rio
texas more than 20 000 haitians are now
reportedly gathered in colombia and may
soon be headed to the u.s nbc is
reporting dhs is monitoring this group
as well as groups of about fifteen
hundred migrants in panama and three
thousand in peru border czar vice
president kamala harris is facing
criticism even on msnbc for not doing
more to address the search meanwhile the
white house is being pressed on why
foreign nationals are required to be
vaccinated but migrants are not here's
our peter ducey asking press secretary
jenn saki about that yesterday
if somebody walks
into the country right across the river
did somebody ask them to see
their vaccination card
well let me explain to you again peter
how our process works as individuals as
individuals come across the border
and they are uh both assessed for
whether they have uh any symptoms if
they have symptoms they are the
intention is for them to be quarantined
that is our process they're not
intending to stay here for a lengthy
period of time
harris this is against the backdrop
however of thousands of them being
released into our states
seemingly permanently with really high
coverage does she is she making that up
like if she goes along she reading that
they don't intend to stay here long
would you think they came all these
thousands of miles so they could tiptoe
in for 15 minutes
like what there's just such a level of
delusion in here right and it's so
disappointing because it didn't have to
be this way and now you have all these
people living in probably arguably worse
quality conditions from where they're
coming from and they just got hit by an
earthquake and their president was
murdered like i mean haiti is no picnic
but now they they come here and this is
not the land of the free that they're
hearing about by the way
senator marsha blackburn was was in
focus with me yesterday
and and said
that social media is playing a huge role
in this particularly facebook she's
taking taking an aim at them from the
hill they're getting ready to have some
hearings and do some things on this that
messages are being spread and reaching
people and citizens in haiti and saying
come so it doesn't matter that secretary
of dhs mayorkas and the and the vice
president kamala harris are saying oh
you know don't come no what they hear is
the loud megaphone that's broadcast with
our president of the united states
saying oh but you can come and he's been
saying that since he flipped the switch
on day one from donald trump's
presidential policies to his own just as
if he was answering a campaign pro
promise to some progressives because he
probably was
i mean where do we go from here and now
the midnight images
that the things that that normally are
happening in dark are happening in the
daytime the rounding up of folk and and
deporting deporting them that is a
horrible look
he doesn't i mean i agree with my last
guest last hour jason meister who worked
for the trump campaign he doesn't have a
base now
nobody's going to trust him right and
the green light that is sort of being
amplified on social media is certainly
it's only surging now because many of
those migrants have been in third
countries for the last year or plus
because we no longer have the remaining
mexico policy because we no longer
enforce our border then then the green
light being spread on social media is
being extra heard and that's why the
surge is occurring wow exactly and kaley
we have um a sound bite from our
president which will play for you get
your reaction on the other side and
whether we can believe in fact anything
that comes out of this president's mouth
we'll take a watch president what's your
reaction to the images throughout the
southern border
get under control
it's simply amazing as he's saying this
what is happening on the hill is senator
hawley is grilling my orcas who is
testifying about his plan hawley said in
private you told me you had a plan when
will this plan stop working to which my
orcis replied it is working to have the
audacity to say something like that it's
an outright lie we've heard lie after
lie just yesterday my orcas said the
border's not open oh wait but migrant
crossings are at a 21-year high there's
no crisis he says but there were over
the weekend 14 000 that was the high
number of folks under the bridge sitting
in human excrement that's half the
population of del rio i think that's
defined as a crisis and then the most
appalling lie from gensake saying they
don't intend to stay right they traveled
1 900 miles to sit in human excrement
and build tents makeshift structures out
of trash bags that's what they did that
makes no sense and we all see these lies
that's right and leo so we talk about
the actual covet spread this from an
administration that seems at least in in
words only to prioritize covet over
everything but the reality is that over
30 percent of these migrants are
refusing the vaccination that the rate
of transmission is above eight percent
reminder public schools were shut at
three percent and the the positivity
rate as they're being disseminated
throughout states i mean it's it's
upwards of of fifteen 000 for example in
mcallen texas these numbers are really
horrifying but it seems as if the
administration only looks at it from a
humane condition if they're republicans
oh let me be very clear emily it's only
if you're an american citizen there is a
inconsistent double standard the people
at the southern border who are entering
this country there is no covet
restrictions there is no covet
requirement there is no vaccine
requirement this is what drives the
american public crazy you're hearing a
mixed message a double standard the
reason why what you see down there which
is a third world country and i submit to
you there's not another place in this
country that looks like that this is
outrageous and what kaylee said the
buying administration is strictly lying
to the american public notwithstanding
what we're seeing and i guarantee you
the only reason why they won't do
anything is because they are afraid i
want to say afraid of their left the
socialist left would chew them up
and casey we have a vice president who's
refused to hold press briefings refused
to visit the southern border refused to
even take and prompt you questions from
reporters and yet now all of a sudden
against the landscape of being
completely mia or missing an inaction as
kaylee says then now she's agreed to go
on a talk show we need a leader not just
talking points your thoughts well she
she decided which football team was
going to get the ball first over the
weekend i mean she flipped a coin at a
college football game over the weekend
while joe biden was riding his bike so
you know there there may be some more
important things on the docket i went to
brian kilmeade i want you to do me a
favor i want you to click to subscribe
to the fox news youtube page this is the
only way that i know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe right now